Hey everyone. I'm Mihaela.
I'm a research engineer at DeepMind.
Hi my name is Feryal. I'm a
research scientist at DeepMind.
I'm also on the board of Women in
Machine Learning
my name is Kate Parkyn
Ii'm a recruitment lead
and I look after all engineering and
research recruitment
I'm generally a very curious person and
I like to
tinker and think about things that might
come up next
and the new possibilities for the
machine learning fields are
very very exciting at the moment.
I feel like my research is something that I
would do as a hobby if I had another job.
It played to my geeky side, It's pretty
phenomenal what we're trying...
what we can do and what we
can leverage through artificial
intelligence and machine learning.
I had a lot of doubts whether I, sort
of, am suited to join DeepMind.
I guess many women and minorities
feel the same
because we don't see a lot of us around.
I was indeed often questioning myself
as in terms of
oh, should you apply
do you think you will be good enough?
While internally you have these
emotional reactions,
the objective reality is that
there's an interview process
there to decide
whether someone is good enough.
Optimise your CV to the best that you
can ensuring that you kind of really
pull out those
technical skills at the top of your CV,
you're really getting across
your background, your skills, your key
achievements. I think networking does
have its advantages and I definitely
encourage
women to network as much as possible.
I would highly recommend
refreshing your basics understandings of
machine learning, computer science.
Focus on breadth rather than depth. If
you're researching just make sure that
you know your basics for
linear algebra, calculus, probability
you can choose which language
you want to code in
I chose Python, some people choose C++
it's quite flexible
If there's anything
in addition that you want to tell us or
really highlight,
you know, cover letters are lovely to
read because ultimately they are
getting across someone's real passion
and desire to want to work for DeepMind.
You know we're not putting people in an
interview setting
to find out reasons not to recruit them.
We want to put them in a comfortable
setting to find out the best reasons to
recruit them
I think during the interview process I
was very conscious of,
I guess, being a woman,
not having done an internship
at DeepMind before.
I felt like I maybe don't belong.
But throughout the
interview process I think
after like
talking to researchers,  and
seeing that I can hold the conversation
and I can sort of answer
questions i felt more confident.
I actually went in with my
three-month-old son.
They just understood
instantly, you know
where I was at in terms of
being a first-time mum,
on maternity, very sleep deprived.
So that really helped, kind of,
eliminate some of
the self-doubt that I was having around
my own
ability and confidence
was actually the
supportive nature of the team
In the machine learning team, this is
of one of the most
inclusive teams that
I've ever worked in.
It's just a very great
atmosphere of
overall growth.
And actually what's quite
organic about DeepMind is actually this
this sort of natural mentoring that
takes place
and that's amongst everybody.
I certainly think that certain
organisations such as
WiML, that allow women
to get together and discuss both
technical challenges that they face in
terms of research but also
personal challenges in terms of
representation and and so on are very
very important
You do not need a PhD to work at DeepMind.
I did not have a PhD
when I joined DeepMind,
I do not have a PhD now.
You really don't need a
PhD necessarily
Of course that depends on the
role that
you're applying for
I think only for research scientists
role,
you definitely need to have a PhD
You need to apply.
Just apply.
Don't wait for
you to feel like something
needs to click.
If you are good enough,
if you've done
the work,
if you are confident in your skills
just apply.
If you get that tingly moment
when you're reading up about us
or we become that kind of niggle in
the back of your head,
if you're well,
if you know if you know our research,
you should definitely,
you're definitely ready.